à savoir la sauvegarde du patrimoine
religieux nos deux collègues and
pantalon qu'il doit être derrière son
écran et les électeurs en déplacement
pour le 4-2 dans le cadre d'un groupe
d'amitié à l'étranger meehan je crois et
parce que joindre à nous par
visioconférence et bien aux liasses qu
est bien présent nos deux collègues qui
prive nous présenterons la semaine
prochaine
le rapport qu'il prépare depuis
plusieurs mois au nom de notre
commission sur le sujet du patrimoine
religieux mais tu crois que pierre
bouzou vias interviendra dans quelques
minutes pour nous dire non pas le
contenu du rapport puisqu'il n'est pas
présentée officiellement mes
interventions ne sera pas très loin
j'imagine de ce que sera le contenu qui
sera présenté la semaine prochaine nous
souhaitions est évidemment bénéficier de
votre expérience sur cette question du
patrimoine religieux je crois que c'est
à peu près 40% du patrimoine des
français
votre mission poursuit en effet un
double objectif ou un triple objectif
celui d'identifier le patrimoine en
danger celui de contribuer à la
restauration et bien sûr à la balle
orange gestion de ce patrimoine nous
savons que ce patrimoine religieux comme
je le disais à l'instant représentent
une part importante des dossiers qui lui
sont soumis chaque année
d'où nos questions dans quel état
jugez-vous ce patrimoine
vous paraît-il vraiment menacé en quoi
le loto du patrimoine permettent ils de
contribuer à sa sauvegarde la pérennité
du loto est elle désormais assurée ou
avec des craintes sur ce sujet et enfin
faut-il faire davantage pour sauver le
patrimoine religieux et le cas échéant
comment autant de questions importantes
sur cette île sur ce sujet et je ne
doute pas que mes collègues
interviendront pour compléter ou abordé
d'autres questions à travers leurs
prises de parole dans quelques instants
mais avant de leur céder la parole je
vous cède la parole pour un propos
liminaire et puis après comme nous
avions l'habitude de le faire nous
échangerons scrabble de questions
réponses
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci à tous d'être présents et de
m'accueillir au sein de cette noble
institution pour pour parler du
patrimoine chaque fois que j'ai eu à
parler devant le sénat de patrimoine
j'ai toujours entonne reçu un accueil
favorable je sais que c'est cette maison
est toujours sensible à ce qui se passe
dans nos territoires et particulièrement
la manière dont le patrimoine impacte
directement la vie économique de nos
territoires et parle évidemment du
patrimoine religieux est quelque chose
d'important parce que c'est sans doute
le point là où le bât blesse dans la
question patrimoniale en france le
patrimoine castrale finalement se porte
relativement bien dans la mesure où tout
est fait puisque il ya beaucoup de
visiteurs eh bien on fait en sorte de le
restaurer pour accueillir des visiteurs
il ya une finalité le patrimoine
industriel est en très mauvais état en
tout cas le patrimoine naturel du 19e
siècle nous essayons avec la mission
berne de le restaurer dans la mesure du
possible mais 30% des dossiers
d'étudiants avec la fondation du
patrimoine et bien concerne directement
le patrimoine religieux qu'ils soient
classés ou non protégé ou non qu'ils
soient en activité j'allais dire c'est à
dire sacralisé ou désacraliser et c'est
assez important et le hasard du
calendrier a fait que cette semaine j'ai
dû me pencher sur les toutes les
demandes qui émanent est à la fois des
drac et des deux des délégués régionaux
delà de la fondation du patrimoine pour
choisir les sites qui seraient dans le
maillage territorial qu'on annoncera la
fin du mois d'août pour le loto du
patrimoine c'est à dire un site par
département j'ai encore une fois été mes
bébés mais vraiment choqué par le nombre
de petites églises de nos campagnes qui
sont dans un état de déréliction
extrêmement avancé et je crois que la
cia il y à un point j'essaye de
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer dans notre pays il ya évidemment
et là je n'ai pas à faire de
commentaires je constate comme vous
comme tous une déchristianisation du
pays qui fait que les églises ne sont
plus fréquentes et quand elles ne sont
plus fréquentes et elles ne sont plus
entretenues d'autres pas il ya une autre
chose c'est que dans la ligne budgétaire
des communes qui ont à la charge des
églises la ligne budgétaire d'entretien
du patrimoine et bien cette ligne est
souvent mise à profit d'autres choses
c'est à dire qu on n'entretient plus le
patrimoine et toute personne qui dispose
d'un bien ce soit un petit appartement
ou quoi que ce soit vous savez très bien
que si vous n'entretenait pas chaque
année votre patrimoine ils se dégradent
et le coût final pour restaurer un
patrimoine dégradé et c'est exponentiel
donc la facture est encore plus lourde
donc je vois ça partout c'est à dire que
pourquoi je fais le lien avec la
déchristianisation c'est que ce n'est
plus un enjeu électoral
c'est à dire que dans les petites
communes on ne se fait par élire maire
en disant je vais sauver l'église du
village en revanche je vais construire
un stade je vais vous aider pour le
transport scolaire etc rallye ça c'est
je le remarque dans dans tous les
villages où je me rends
cc je vois des églises dans un très
mauvais état de conservation
les dracs aide dans la mesure du
possible à hauteur de 30 ou 40 % mais la
somme qui est nécessaire pour les pour
les 20% qui restent à la charge d'eads
et des municipalités et bien souvent les
municipalités ne veulent pas jules
assiste à des conseils municipaux ils
refusent de soutenir les travaux de
l'église donc il ya des mères très
courageux qui le font qu'y qu'il impose
d'autres n'ont pas peut-être cet
entregent en tout cas cette même
sensibilité au patrimoine donc je vois
des vous voulez une vision très
contrastées une chose est sûre c'est que
nous avons énormément d'église de nos
campagnes qui sont dans un très mauvais
état et moi ce qui me choque c'est que
voyez vous on n'a pas réussi encore à
faire comprendre que parfois
l'église de campagne c'est peut-être la
seule chose qui reste dans les villages
de la culture parce que dans certains
villages il n'y a plus que ça c'est à
dire où on peut voir un tableau on peut
voir une oeuvre d'art une sculpture on
peut voir un bâtiment roman ou gothique
c'est et est donc ces essais de la
culture où c'est pas seulement du culte
c'est de la culture ouverte à tous
disponibles à portée de main c'est de
l'art et de la culture a vraiment de
proximité et ça on a on n'a pas réussi a
encore à le faire passer auprès il se
trouve que le hasard encore une fois du
calendrier fait que ce soir il ya le
village préféré des français d'objets
j'ai pu arpenter toute la france pour
voir nos villages je pense à la bouille
par exemple où le faisait au maire mais
il faut sauver votre clocher c'est quand
même pas possible on est quelques
quelques kilomètres ça pour catherine
morin desailly on est juste à côté de
rouen je sais mais c'est pas possible
d'avoir votre clocher sushis les coûts
il faut le voulons restaurer mais oui
mais vous comprenez on a un problème
aussi d'ingénérie
administratives et là je touche du doigt
un autre point c'est que quand vous êtes
un maire d'une petite commune rurale que
vous avez 100 200 300 habitants vous
avez une secrétaire de mairie qui vous
aide pour l'état civil pour les
différentes questions parce que les
maires sont très solides
pour pour
pour des demandes de subventions donc il
ya toute cette charge avait proposé
depuis longtemps mais ça n'a pas elle je
n'ai pas été entendu qu'il y ait à la
mise mise à disposition des maires d amo
d assistance à la maîtrise d'ouvragé de
telle sorte qu'on puisse les aider à a
présenté les dossiers parce que faute de
dossier crédit remonte sont pas dépensés
en face et vous connaissez ça mieux que
moi donc il ya là une un cercle vicieux
qui est qu'il faut arrêter de toute
urgence parce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans dans le jeu un état d'
alerte sur nos églises de campagne et
d'autant que avec les regroupements des
communes et les communautés de communes
vous avez parfois des communautés de
communes qui se retrouve avec 7 8 10
église et qui me disent les présidente
d'aidés comme comme me dise va falloir
en sacrifier une ou deux parce que nous
on peut pas tout les sauver et donc ça
c'est un discours que moi je refuse
d'entendre mais que j'ai entendu dans
les plus hautes sphères de l'état et et
et contre lequel je bah c'est à dire que
je pense qu'un pays qui n'est pas
capable d'entretenir son patrimoine
religieux c'est pas une question de
culte c'est une question de culture
c'est une question de
respect de notre histoire de ce qui a
fait les les racines de notre de notre
pays on le doit et puis c'est aussi un
non sens économique
c'est à dire que je souvent il se trouve
dans mon village les gens viennent et
vont voir l'église la première chose
qu'ils vont voir is garé devant ils
entrent et ils me disent mais vous avez
vu dans quel état elle est chez ben oui
mais voilà il faut le dire au maire on
l'aide je l'aide mais c'est pas simple
vous voyez donc c'est la première chose
la première chose que font les gens
c'est d'aller voir l'église du village
elle est au centre du village comme on
disait autrefois et donc quand elle est
dans un mauvais état et vous pas savoir
le nombre de on a tellement attendu que
maintenant on est dans un état de
catastrophe
c'est à dire que la mission bien ne
répondent à des clochers qui sont
effondrés la foudre qui est tombée dès
des pans entiers de murs qui se sont
qui sont tombés enfin c'est vraiment
l'état de catastrophe et donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait c'est à dire on est on est
sous l'avalanche de projet vous avez
j'imagine vu les gens de la fondation du
patrimoine ils peuvent le dire c'est
vraiment on est très sollicités pour
sauver les petites églises de campagne
alors que nous on essaye avec la mission
berne d'être équilibré entre le
patrimoine vernaculaire le patrimoine
religieux le patrimoine castrale le
patrimoine du xxème siècle le patrimoine
industriel et les maisons des illustres
on est obligé mais c'est énorme de voir
sur 7,8 typologie de patrimoine 30% de
l'ensemble de la mission concerne le
patrimoine religieux c'est la grande
majorité des sujets qui nous viennent
qui remonte des petites communes de
300-400 mêmes habitants parce que le
coût d'une église à restaurer tout
toujours autour d'un million et demi et
quand vous êtes dans une ville c'est
plus simple mais quand vous êtes dans
une commune de 200 ou 300 âmes c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'atteindre donc
il faut d'urgence qu'on se mobilise pour
sauver ce patrimoine religieux et j'en
termine avec un point c'est que ce
patrimoine au logis aussonne l'émission
c'est pas seulement les églises c'est
aussi des églises réformée et
luthérienne
on a j'étais content de voir je n'ai pas
pu y aller mais à verdun la synagogue de
verdun était restauré il ya eu celle de
thann aussi parce que vous savez les
églises les synagogues pardon en alsace
il ya une vitalité du judaïsme en alsace
pendant des années aujourd'hui c'est
moins le cas ça appartient à des
communes ne savent pas quoi en faire
faut les restaurer de même pour
certaines églises réformée protestante
et puis des temples tamouls que nous
avons restauré sur l'île de la réunion
des temples indiens et également de
telle sorte que aucune aucune foi n'a
été mise de côté donc quand je parle de
patrimoine religieux c'est tout le
patrimoine religieux quels que soient
les fois qu'ils sont qui sont pratiqués
dans notre pays
merci pour ce propos liminaire qui
évidemment fait écho à beaucoup de
préoccupation que nous partageons avec
vous sans plus tarder fut donné la
parole à pierre housieaux ya peut-être
and mental ont scellé dans son écran
interviendra également nous fassiez un
point sur la mission qui sera présenté
la semaine prochaine merci monsieur le
président bonjour monsieur berne je vais
je parlais aussi au nom de ventalon avec
laquelle nous avons travaillé dans dans
un consensus absolu donc j'utiliserai un
pluriel simple uriel de majesté
républicaine mais c'est pour témoigner
de du travail qu'on a fait tous les deux
nous partageons l'essentiel de votre
constat et nous sommes arrivés au bout
de quelques mois de cette mission à peu
près au même au même bilan avec quelques
nuances sur sur les chiffres la france
et 100000 édifices religieux ce qui est
l'un des plus gros patrimoines culturels
européens peut-être après l'italie c'est
quarante mille édifice qui sont encore
utilisés pour pour le culte ce qu'est ce
qui est considérable et parmi ces 40
milliards à 15 milles seulement qu'ils
sont protégés c'est à dire que
l'essentiel du patrimoine religieux
aujourd'hui
à protéger ce qui est évidemment un
problème majeur alors vous avez parlé de
déchristianisation
je préfèrerais parler de baisse d'une
certaine pratique religieuse je serai
sap l'union c'est sûr sur le propos je
pense qu' il peut y avoir aujourd'hui
notamment après l'écho vide des formes
d'expression religieuse qui ne passe pas
nécessairement par le culte dans un
édifice ce qui ne rend pas les choses
plus faciles pour autant
il ya environ d'alors on a énormément de
difficultés à avoir des chiffes
solidifier puisque le ministère de la
culture a abandonné tout travail
d'inventaire dans ce domaine et c'est
quand même un gros problème on pense que
il ya entre 2000 et 3000 édifices
religieux dans lesquelles le culte est
extrêmement sporadiques voire inexistant
et la question vous l'avez dit c'est
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire pour
justifier auprès des gens qui payent
leurs impôts le fait que ces édifices
qui sont des biens communaux doivent
être continue doivent continuer à être
entretenu ouvert et là on a été très
surpris de voir qu'il ya un consensus
général
y compris du clergé que nous avons
rencontrés à plusieurs reprises et tout
le monde pense qu'il faut socialiser ces
édifices du culte c'est à dire pas
abandonner leur vocation religieuse
quand elles existent mais permettre
d'autres activités pour que la société
est très souvent la société villageoise
la petite communauté villageoise
s'emparent de ce patrimoine en y
développant des activités qui permettent
de justifier auprès de la commune qu'on
puisse continuer à engager des fonds sur
leur race leur restauration il y a une
un bilan qui avait été fait il ya une
vingtaine d'années et il n'était pas
arrivée jusqu'à cette conclusion par
manque de consensus aujourd'hui 20 ans
après on peut vous assurer que tout le
monde est d'accord et que ministre du
culte
affectataire communes veulent travailler
sur la co affectation sur une
affectation partager 2 de ces dix villes
de cet édifice et ça nous semble
extrêmement importante le bilan qu'on
fait mais vous le connaissez comme nous
malheureusement c'est que
c'est plus domaine de l'état l'état mais
il sert la culture direction du
patrimoine drac nous a dit sur le
patrimoine non protégé
nous c'est fini mais avec la dureté avec
laquelle je voulais qu ce prix on est
incapable avec nos moyens humains nos
moyens budgétaires
d'apporter de la maîtrise de l'aide à la
maîtrise d'ouvragé aux collectivités et
que quelques financements donc les
solutions existent mais plus du côté de
l'état est ce qu'on a essayé de faire
avec avec ce rapport c'est de montrer
que il peut exister à une autre échelle
dans la relation entre la commune et le
département des solutions intéressantes
à la fois pour apporter de la maîtrise
d'ouvragé est aussi un peu d'argent ce
qu'il ya quelques ressources budgétaires
qui pourraient être
mobilisés donc la question de fond et
c'est là aussi où je vous interpelle un
peu c'est est ce que le moment n'est pas
venu sans se lancer dans une grande loi
de réfléchir aux différents niveaux de
compétences de l'état des collectivités
sur le patrimoine
nous avons le sentiment que le
patrimoine de proximité non protégé doit
être sorti de la compétence de l'état
qui n'exerce plus et on doit aujourd'hui
donner aux collectivités essentiellement
départements et communes - la région des
outils pour apporter aux communes ce
dont elles deux ont besoin et dont vous
avez témoignés très justement c'est à
dire cette impossibilité de mobiliser de
la maîtrise d'ouvragé pour faire face à
des travaux qui sont complexes et aller
chercher des subventions qui existe qui
existe ce très souvent il ya de l'argent
mais les petites communes ne savent pas
comment aller le chercher j'étais très
heureux de vous entendre parler des
sinagots alsacienne parce que c'est un
problème majeur que nous n'avions pas vu
et que nous avons découvert pendant
cette mission alors les synagogues est
la sienne du fait du concordat ils sont
pas prêts rayés td commune mais
propriété des édifices publics du culte
et dans dans le haut rhin notamment dans
shingo aujourd'hui les communautés je
vais non plus de moyens et tout ce
patrimoine est en train d'être vendue
transformé de telle façon que il peut y
avoir un risque dans quelque temps que
les édifices liés à la pratique du culte
juif en alsace disparaisse complètement
alors que ça a été le coeur de la
judaïté française et que nous devons
notamment par rapport à tout ce qui
s'est passé au moment de la seconde
annexion un effort de solidarité
nationale pour sauver ce patrimoine et
on le dit avec ma collègue à nos ventes
allant avec un peu de solennité là il y
a un dossier national et je suis très
heureux que vous ennuyer parler parce
que c'est quelque chose qui nous a
vraiment perturbé
j'enfile à monsieur le président
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est à
dire que sur sur la compétence la
répartition des compétences je vous
donne un exemple moi je
finalement c'est ce qu'on voit au
quotidien qui le plus simple notre
église abbatiale dans village était en
mauvais état il ya des problèmes pour
pour la restaurer on a trouvé beaucoup
d'argent mais il ya plusieurs plusieurs
tranches de travaux on s'est dit mais
les habitants se sont désintéressés de 2
des travaux qui durent depuis une
dizaine d'années parce qu'à l'intérieur
une voix il ne voit rien avancer il ne
voit rien tokyo 11 et 10 dimanche
dernier on va nettoyer l'église c'est à
dire elle fait 64 mètres de long
deuxième édifice religieux le plus
important de raynouard après la
cathédrale de chat c'est pas rien on
était on a une association qui s'appelle
sauvegarde de l'église abbatiale on est
on est allés tous mais la drac nous a
donné juste des recommandations c'est à
dire vous n'avez pas le droit d'utiliser
tel chiffon patel valeurs on nous donne
des indications et puis nous on a nos
bras nous nos mains et on y va donc vous
voyez il ya là une déconnexion totale
entre ce qui se passe dans la réalité du
terrain et puis alors ça c'est la faute
du fait de ces grandes régions puisque
notre drac et à orly envoyé à 2h30 de
route donc si vous voulez on se fasse il
nous donnait et encore ils font beaucoup
d'efforts parce qu'ils viennent chaque
fois que c'est nécessaire et donc avec
notre bonne volonté on essaye de faire
des choses pour qu'au moins les
visiteurs voient une église en état de
2,2 de fonctionnement là vous avez mille
fois raison c'est que le culte et
sporadiques
la messe dans cette église abbatiale qui
est spectaculaire quand même karen de
navires renversé elle fait il ya une
messe toutes les sept semaines huit
semaines et pour une vingtaine de
personnes donc ma critique et pas du
tout de la vous après on utilise les
mots au con con qu'on veut pour dire des
christie nation ou baisse du culte il ya
d'autres formes de culte vous avez
raison de le souligner mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que un édifice
religieux dans lequel on entre plus ils
se dégradent parce que plus personne ne
voit les dégradations qui s'y produisent
les pierres qui tombent c'est la même
chose d'ailleurs pour tous les palais
archiépiscopal
j'ai eu cette discussion avec
l'archevêque de strasbourg qui me disait
je ne chauffe plus le palais puisque le
saint père nous autorise plus à
l'habiter il vit dans un deux pièces
cuisine et donc le palette est ouvert
pour les journées du patrimoine
par chance à rouen le palais
archiépiscopal a été réutilisé pour
l'historial de de jeanne d'arc donc au
moins il a on lui a donné une nouvelle
vocation ce qui est frappant dans ce que
vous dites et qui rejoint la réalité de
la mission c'est que souvent on est
alerté par des
dans l'édifice religieux vous avez aussi
tout ce qui est les couvents les
monastères tout c'est énorme patrimoine
religieux des congrégations religieuses
sinon qu'ils n'ont plus lieu d'être il
n'y a plus il ya plus de moines plus de
plus deux religieuses dans certaines
régions je pense par exemple aux eaux à
tréguier les soeurs de trégunc nous
appellent tous les ans elle dépose un
dossier tous les ans c'est énorme énorme
alors on les a aidés en 2018 c'est vrai
que pour les sites emblématiques de
cette année a dit on va encore aider les
soeurs de tréguier mais ce qui m'a
frappé dans leurs projets de
restauration c'est le projet de
valorisation
c'est à dire de se dire mais elles se
sont dit mais et elles ont raison c'est
au fond l'accueil des mois n'a plus de
sens ou dégoût des ou des moniales en
revanche l'accueil des enfants autistes
l'accueil d'un accueil on reste dans la
charité on reste dans la dent dans la
vocation religieuse initial mais
peut-être on peut l'aide sociale l'aide
aux personnes défavorisées l'aide aux
handicapés
l'aide aux
intergénérationnel faire en sorte que
les jeunes étudiants puissent vivre avec
des personnes
qui sont en extrême dépendance d'eau
qu'il ya là des projets à établir nous
on essaye de les aider parce que
voyez-vous dans la mission on n'aide que
quand il ya un vrai projet de
revalorisation
c'est le sauver le patrimoine pour le
sauver simplement pour que ce soit joli
ça n'a plus de sens aujourd'hui il faut
retrouver une raison d'être et enfin
voilà il faut donner du sens et enfin la
dernière chose les raisons c'est les
compétences je pense que ça n'a plus
il faudrait que ça soit que les
communautés de communes et je vois que
mon département par exemple eure-et-loir
le président du département est très
soucieuse il a comme autrefois albéric
de montgolfier
il a il a donné de l'argent pour qu' on
puisse restaurer toutes les petites
églises de
2,2 du département ça c'est je pense
qu'il faut remettre niveau de
compétences aux départements avec les
communes avec une réserve si vous y
autorise et celle je pense qu'il
faudrait comme il ya la commission du
vieux paris j'espère qu'elle fonctionne
toujours et parfois j'en doute montant
bon ça c'est de nous deux sujets il
faudrait qu'une commission qui puisse de
façon très très pérenne puisse juger de
l'importance patrimoniale des lieux ce
que fait normalement la direction
générale des patrimoines mais qu'il faut
renforcer au niveau local je pense que
par exemple le président de la région
normandie et aux raisons de nommer un
conseiller patrimoine pour pour sa
région parce que c'est important d'avoir
une expertise de 2,2 ce qui est urgent
qu'on ne fasse pas n'importe quoi vous
voyez je suis très contente pas y aller
avec des seaux d'eau reste heureux veut
nettoyer l'église on y va avec des
chiffons qui sont spéciaux qui n'abîme
pas les statuts qui n'abîme pas les
oeuvres des tête de loup permettre dans
les toiles d'araignées sans abîmer les
oeuvres voilà il faut il faut qu'on
puisse avoir dans chaque région dans
chaque département au niveau
départemental puisque c'est ce que vous
dit très justement il faut qu'il dise
experts aussi qui protège le patrimoine
s'il n'ya plus la compétence de la drac
il faut imaginer notre compétence pour
pour éviter que des erreurs dramatiques
soit commise en tout cas il ya peut-être
un exemple que j'aimerais dire pour
qu'on comprenne bien l'enjeu du
patrimoine religieux
j'avais alerté le président de la
république le ministère de la culture
lorsque la catho de lille a voulu
détruire l'église saint joseph pour
construire des bâtiments qui rapportait
sans doute plus qui était d'aider des
deux logements pour les étudiants j'ai
dit vous allez avoir un vrai problème
politique à partir du moment vous
laisser détruire ce bâtiment tout le
monde a donné son feu vert la gâteau la
demande et la ville de lille a donné son
feu vert franck riester qui est alors
ministre de la culture a demandé un
moratoire
et puis ensuite il ya une lettre du dg
pattes qui a dit au fond il n'y a aucune
valeur patrimoniale dans cette église du
19e siècle permis de démolir elle a été
démolie mais vous n'imaginez pas le choc
c'est à dire que on est dans un pays où
les français sont alors il ne fréquente
peut-être pas l'église il mais ils sont
choqués quand vous détruisez une église
c et je les comprends je trouve que
détruire le patrimoine religieux c'est
s'est fait refaire comment faire outrage
à notre mémoire collective de la même
chose et là où je vous rejoins pour
pourquoi j'ai été émue par le sort
d'aider des synagogues de
d'alsace c'est que c'est notre mémoire
collective
de même que les les églises réformées
aussi et donc il y a c'est faire outrage
à notre mémoire collective que de
laisser à l'abandon ces églises et de me
dire au volant y en a bien une sur sept
combats pouvoir détruit non donc je
pense qu'il faut trouver des solutions
ensemble par la loi par part peut-être
imaginer des scénarios vous avez raison
il ya plein de gens qui se mobilisent il
ya par exemple j'ai on arrive bien
collectif de chefs d'entreprise pour
avec la fondation du patrimoine pour
église en péril
sauver ces petites églises de campagne
et je remercie un certain nombre de mes
scènes et je veux donner qu'un exemple
j'avais le maire de beauce m qui eux qui
la baussaine pardon pardon la mède le
maire de la baussaine c'est chez vous et
le maire de la beauce m qui m'a appelé
mais besoin de l'argent pilotto du
patrimoine et il a trouvé qu aimer
passait on a donné 40 mille cinquante
mille et puis il se plaint et moi je
suis un jour à la télévision et je dis
je suis désolé parfois la première année
c'était en 2018 j'ai voulu aider 250
monument au lieu de 100 qu'on fait par
an maintenant évidemment le gâteau quand
il est plus grands la part est plus
petit évidemment quand vous le partagez
alors que le loto rapporte bon an mal an
plus de 25 millions d'euros par an et
bien eu ce qui skie françois pinault m'a
entendu le dire à la télévision il m'a
appelé il m'a dit il manque combien pour
la baussaine il a payé la somme qui
manquait je le dis parce que il ya des
mécènes ya des générosités il ya des
gens qui sont prêts à aider l'église du
village où la synagogue de l'heure de
leur village on a trouvé l'argent par
exemple on parlait de verdun j'ai initié
le projet de verdun avec la fondation du
patrimoine et la fondation du judaïsme
français a mis la 1000e a dit ben on
suit le projet doit vous voyez vous
arrivez quand vous quand vous initier un
projet c'est un peu un jeu de dominos
c'est à dire que tout le monde sait ça
sert de levier en fait et je crois qu'on
peut arriver à sauver monument par
monument
pardon je suis toujours très longtemps
mais réponse je vous prie de m'excuser
olivier paccaud sonia de la provôté
sylvie robert et bruno retailleau
et merci michel au casino merci stéphane
bern pour
votre engagement et votre passion votre
foi votre amour du patrimoine c'est vrai
que la france est un dieu un pays béni
des dieux du patrimoine pierre a rappelé
les 40000 édifices religieux ça peut
dans certains cas être considéré comme
une charge ça doit à mon avis est plutôt
considéré comme une chance comme un
atout pour l'attractivité de nos
territoires
j'ai eu moi personnellement le plaisir
de mener avec notre collègue joseph qui
n'est pas là de rendre un rapport sur
l'utilisation des crédits dévolus au
patrimoine dans le cadre du plan de
relance et beaucoup de choses très
positives ont été faites le plan
cathédrale par exemple mais là aussi la
ruralité avait été oubliée alors vous
insister dessus vous avez bien insisté
sur le fait que l'église est bien plus
qu'un lieu de culte c'est un lieu de
culture
c'est un lieu social moi ce week-end
comme la plupart mes collègues j'ai fait
plein de manifestations j'en ai fait 10
sur 10 j'en ai trois qui ont eu pour
cadre une église
une paroissienne à ravenel a remis digne
60000 euros de don à une association de
de réfection de la commune a réuni dans
le vexin il y avait une exposition de
peinture et à saint thibault on a posé
un coq au dessus de du clocher alors
j'ai une question très précise qui
rejoint un peu ce qu'a dit pierrot zulia
tout à l'heure sur la notion de co
affectation dans mon département de
l'oise la plupart des églises se porte
pas si mal que ça parce qu'on a la
chance d'avoir un département du
conseiller départemental qui met pas mal
d'argent sur l'entretien son patrimoine
parce que la région commence à m parce
que l'état via la detr ce qu'il ne
faisait pas auparavant commencent à
mettre aussi un petit peu parce qu'il ya
des communautés de communes qui mettent
il ya une communauté de communes c'est
celle des sablons qui depuis 20 ans a
entretenu tout son patrimoine elle a
rénové les 21 lise y en a que 20 me
c'est déjà beaucoup les 21 glisse
maintenant le patrimoine castrale donc
tout le monde s'y est mis alors je ne
sais pas si le fait de donner un chef de
file à pour la compétence entretien du
patrimoine sera une bonne chose parce
que quand tout le monde s'y met on peut
avoir des résultats remarquables faut
simplement une volonté en ce qui
concerne l'accord effectué à sion je
vais vous donner un exemple dans mon
département j'ai une commune s'appelle
catillon fumichon
c'était deux communes qui ont fusionné à
la fin des années 60 qui dit de communes
dit deux églises et ses deux églises
c'était compliqué pour la municipalité
de les entretenir ils ont fait un choix
qui a pu étonner surprendre voire un
tout petit peu choqué au début ils ont
décidé de transformer l'une des églises
celle de café catillon en mairie
salle polyvalente c'est la plus belle
salle polyvalente de l'oise avec des
vitraux merveilleux c'est peut-être la
plus belle église de l'oise alors est-ce
que alors il ya beaucoup de communes
d'une certaine taille qui ont plusieurs
églises et qui ont pu parce qu'elle
avait été désaffectée occulte les
transformer en lieux dédiés à la
pratique notamment culturel lieu
d'exposition mais justement est ce que
cette conversion entre guillemets des
édifices religieux
vous choque qu'est ce que ça vous semble
au contraire une voie pour faciliter un
meilleur entretien
une meilleure transmission de ces
pierres de ses vieilles pierres est ce
que c'est une piste à creuser à votre
avis parce que
beaucoup de gens le souhaiterait enfin
moi je les constate et et quand pierre
tout à l'heure a dit qu'il y avait un
consensus moi je connais des prêtres qui
ont pas envie qu'ils aient des
concernant leurs églises par exemple
l'évêque de beauvais et pas trop chaud
quand on lui dit qu'il va y avoir un
concert il veut savoir de quoi il s'agit
ici c'est pas du gospel il en veut pas
trop voilà donc est-ce qu'il faut pas
creuser là dessus voilà
ce n'est la provoquer
oui mais merci beaucoup effectivement
c'est un
grand sujet c'est un sujet du patrimoine
religieux
et nous avions avec michel dagbert à
l'initiative de la délégation
collectivités territoriales produit un
rapport concernant le les maires face à
l'europe un patrimoine historique et
très rapidement c'est vraiment la
question des édifices religieux qui
arrivait au premier plan avec notamment
un événement qui a été non négligeable
deux événements non négligeable dans
cette affaire le fait que le l'état
n'assure plus l'assistance à maîtrise d
ouvrage or ces coisy le noeud du
problème c'est à dire à la fois monté
faire le diagnostic
monter le tout ce qui est nécessaire
pour mettre en oeuvre une rénovation ou
une
parfois massives des bâtiments et puis
le montage financier parce que ça reste
un sujet important et on sait que dans
le patrimoine religieux une très grande
majorité n'est pas classé et donc il ya
un vrai sujet de
du fait que ce patrimoine échappe aux
écrans radar mais pas tout à fait c'est
dire qu'à partir du moment où l'état
décide d'accompagner ou les
collectivités décide d'accompagner et
bien à ce moment là même nom classé les
contraintes arrive en pagaille
et donc je souhaitais
dire que il ya peut-être un sujet sur le
classement et trouver une façon de
pouvoir accompagner en être en étant
moins moins ambitieux sur le montant des
factures
et les le programme qui est proposé
parce que les mères moi j'ai encore un
exemple tout récent un maire qui avait
bouclé son budget
l'état propose d'accompagner dans le
cadre de prendre du plan de relance
église donc là c'est la bf intervient on
demande un architecte du patrimoine mais
on demande des entreprises spécialisées
la facture est mutilé par 20 et sa
touche pas commencé alors qu'il ya un an
le chantier aurait pu commencer 2 il ya
je pense qu'il ya une forme d'urgence
qui nécessite une forme d'urgence
administrative
qui permettrait de d'investir
massivement le deuxième événement
éléments ce sont les communes nouvelles
vous l'avez justement signalé et
de la part de l'accompagnement de l'état
il est
nécessaire
d'accompagner plus c'est comme une
nouvelle qui a dix communes rurales 8000
habitants se retrouvent avec cet édifice
religieux à gérer je pense qu'on pense à
la même
commune nouvelle et donc on voit bien
que la ce est incommensurable on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas y parvenir le
deuxième sujet c'est le sujet de
l'entretien jaillir les questions la
question des églises en france c'est la
question de l'entretien du patrimoine en
france c'est à dire qu'on retrouve au
sujet des églises toutes les
problématiques contrat au niveau du
patrimoine et donc là tous les ans au
moment du projet de loi de finances où
on intervient sur la question du budget
entretien du patrimoine et cette veille
nécessaires avant qu'on arrive à des
arrêtés de péril et
clairement il serait bien qu'ils aient
un budget entretien au niveau des drac
et qui mériterait d'être restitués
destiné à ce patrimoine religieux
parce que
on voit bien que quand il faut entre
protégé à un clocher ou le refaire
intégralement il ya il ya une facture
qui est complètement
différente et puis le dernier sujet
c'est dire aussi que les églises sont
des musées dans les églises il y à des
tableaux
inauguré les travaux d'une église ce
week end et des tableaux de peintres
flamands extraordinaire face il ya les
tableaux il ya le mobilier les objets
que les objets d'office et de culte les
statuts etc etc et tout se passerait des
registres aussi il ya des registres qui
date du moyen âge dans certaines petites
églises on ne sait même pas et je pense
que au delà de l'inventaire du bâti ya
cet inventaire de tout ce mobilier qu'il
faut faire qu'il est nécessaire de faire
parce que ça appartient aussi à nos
trésors nationaux et certains sont
complètement méconnu et et eni protéger
donc
peut-être avoir finalement un référent
haddock par département pour pouvoir
faire ce travail
de collations d2
et d'évaluation de tout le patrimoine
groupe l'ailier liés aux religieux merci
see me robert vous êtes nombreux à
vouloir intervenir donc si vous pouvez
être
synthétique dans les interventions
merci monsieur le président en général
je le suis donc je vais essayer de
l'être de nouveau merci monsieur berne
en tout cas et d'avoir cité jérémy
l'oise est le maire de la baussaine il
vous en est éternellement reconnaissant
parce que c'est vrai que ça a déclenché
la tension françois pinault qui est
d'ailleurs très attentif à ce qui se
passe dans mon département et il a fait
beaucoup de jaloux auprès de pas mal de
mer je peux vous dire en tout cas
c'était une belle une belle aventure à
moi je voudrais attirer l'attention mais
du coup ça prolonge un peu les propos de
de sonia sur le patrimoine mobilier et
sur le fait qu' il faut avoir à l'esprit
le sort de beaucoup de collections de
livres et darche yves des communautés
religieuses et des diocèses qui
d'ailleurs sont devenues propriété de
l'état mais qui sont restés dans les
diocèses et qui sont en grand danger
parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
personnel il n'y a pas de moyens pour
pouvoir les gérer les entretenir et je
le dis d'autant plus que c'est un
patrimoine qui peut disparaître c'est
notre patrimoine national et j'ai
observé et c'est une préoccupation que
je partage avec vous des ventes
publiques de bibliothèques entières de
séminaires de ce dossier zain diocésain
qui sont déjà qui sont en plus pardon de
le dire à la limite de la légalité
et je crois que il faut être vraiment
attentif alors je demandais à pierre si
la mission intégrée cette question du
patrimoine mobilier mais en tout cas sur
la question de ses archives et des
collections de livres qui peuvent être
absolument magnifique je pense qu'il ya
un vrai danger aujourd'hui l'état ne
s'en occupe pas et il n'y a pas vraiment
les personnels et les moyens aujourd'hui
dans les eaux cesse de s'en occuper
voilà monsieur le président je crois
avoir été synthétique mais j'alertais en
tout cas sur une dimension qui me semble
aujourd'hui extrêmement important si
nous aimerions tous avoir françois
pinault dans notre département
bruno retailleau
3 3 éléments d'abord pour remercier ses
fans baird utilise sa notoriété publique
pour une cause d'intérêt général il ya
tellement entre guillemets de people qui
sont tournés vers eux mêmes et je pense
qu'il faut que l'on salue cette activité
qui est une activité qui est une mission
de service public vraiment un immense
merci stéphane bern le deuxième élément
le patrimoine religieux bien sûr il ya
l'aspect culturel qui nous relie à
travers l'histoire aux générations qui
fait que en réalité il ya une question
de transmission on parle de la nature
patrimoine naturel à transmettre mais ça
c'est absolument fondamental il ya
l'aspect économique bien sûr puisque le
les visites touristiques sont aussi en
france des visites du patrimoine
profanes ou religieux et je dirais que
pour nos communes pour nos villages on
n'en parle jamais il ya un aspect
d'urbanisme on est souvent nous élus
locaux fin ancien des locaux ou même
sénateur attaché à l'urbanisme mais vous
enlevez l'église au milieu du village et
le village est déstructurée et ça n'est
certainement pas les pavillons
aujourd'hui qui sont d'anciens champs à
vache transformer en tablette de
chocolat qui vont à mai y aurait le cas
dans la qualité de vie qu'on offre à nos
compatriotes donc ça c'est ses premiers
points que je voulais vous les resituer
quelque chose de plus large d'une
perspective plus large sur l'utilité du
patrimoine de deuxième élément ce que je
veux dire aussi c'est comment fait-on
maintenant pour pour avancer la question
me semble-t-il de concerne que
marginalement le patrimoine protège dans
ma région j'ai été prise en département
j'ai pris en 26 communalité départements
et de régions on a avec l'état une
grille qui nous permette d'avoir à peu
près 80% et parfois même au delà pour
des communes qui sont vie sont pauvres
sur le passage protégé la question c'est
le patrimoine non protégé et dans le
patrimoine religieux je dirais même que
ce sont d'abord les églises du 19e
siècle qui ont été construits un peu à
la va vite sur des architectures parfois
pas toujours top c'est celle là qui sont
qui présente souvent le plusieurs choses
donc moi je pense que il ya plusieurs ya
plusieurs éléments que je veux porter à
votre connaissance sur la question des
compétences moi je suis vous souvenez
dans le cas de la loi note on nous a
vendu à l'époque cette idée que il
fallait plus de financements croisés
parce qu'un jardin à la française c'est
toujours mieux c'est cartésien que c'est
pas ça c'est de la bêtise il faut
préserver la capacité d'avoir plusieurs
financements la communauté de communes
le département et la région et à tous
bien sûr pote la fondation le loto que
c'est pas c'est comme ça qu'on pourra y
arriver et je ne faut surtout pas que
les collectivités
place phone trop faim moi ce que j'ai
fait pour mon département et la région
c'est que je dis aux collectivités match
personne par exemple à 20% à 30% de
500000 euros mais vous faites des
tranches comme ça sur trois ans vous
déclare faux nez et on va jusqu'à amis
en 53 cents donc un attention
compétences de les compétences notamment
en matière départementale je rappelle la
première trans fait la une des grandes
compétences culturelles transféré par
les lois de décentralisation
ça a été le département notamment pour
les archives des appartements je pense
que pour tout ce qui est parce que le
rouge on parle de regroupements de
paroisses aujourd'hui le nombre de noms
mais parfois évidemment il ya moins de
moins en moins de curés mais il ya aussi
les communes nouvelles très bien mais
dans le regroupement des paroisses il va
y avoir des archives qui pourraient
disparaître je pense que c'est le rôle
alors très clairement des archives
département autant je ne veux pas d'un
chef de file à sur le patrimoine
religieux autant sur cette question là
je pense que c'est clairement le
département et on a un corps notamment
qui vient de l'école des sharks et
perras qui est l'un des meilleurs scores
au monde il faut s'appuyer sur deuxième
chose sur les objets d'antiquité
voilà c'est aussi notamment le
département parce que là encore on peut
s'appuyer sur des conservateurs c'est ce
que j'ai fait qu'ils peuvent mettre en
lumière un certain nombre de collections
de chasubles et théâtre d'objet d'objets
cultuels ça c'est et dernière chose sur
les compétences moi je pense lui
évidemment je pense que on part souvent
ici de décentralisation je pense que la
déconcentration ce doit être de redonner
aux préfets de département le rôle de
coordination de toutes les
administrations d'état et je pense qu'
il faudrait soumettre les dracs aussi à
la fin à une forme là aussi d'actions
d'autorité du préfet département parce
que le préfet département il a cette
finesse de l'analyse que n'a pas le
préfet de région et les grosses les gros
administrations départementales drac
directeur afin de vous connaissez comme
moi sont en suspension ce sont des
fausses déconcentration elles sont plus
c'est directement sur leurs
administrations centrales et donc ça ne
fait pas avancer le schmilblic troisième
élément dernier il faut trouver
des utilités nouvelles du sur cultuelle
évidemment quand le culte est toujours
célébrée quand il ya une affectation au
sens de la loi de 1905 mais il faut
vraiment avoir aussi penser à autre
chose ce que quelques exemples un
exemple nous on a mis en valeur derrière
des vitres blindées
les trésors petite église le département
la région subventionner ce qui permet
d'avoir que ce soit sur du tissu
chasuble sûr qu alice et cetera tous les
éléments précieux dans les petites
églises ça permet d'avoir une visite on
peut aussi tard des moyens très simples
aujourd'hui avoir un déclenchement d'une
musique
et aussi d'un commentaire qui permettent
une lecture expliquée ça ce sont des
choses qui permettent de rendre le
patrimoine plus plus accessible de
deuxième chose je pense qu on a sauvé
une église du 19e on ya fait un centre
du vitrail les bancs sont son qui se
retourne très facile c'est le dossier
qui pivote dans un sens quand il a le
culte dans l'autre sens quand c'est pour
le l'exposition temporaire ou
l'exposition permanente mais il peut y
avoir évidemment qu'on va pas être
transformé en boîte de nuit quand elles
sont toujours affectés au culte mais il
peut y avoir dans les communes un objet
culturel des deux salles d'exposition
qui peuvent permettre justement à ce
nouveau patrimoine de retrouver une
raison d'être voilà voilà ce que je
voulais dire très rapidement n'oubliez
pas quand même j'ai bonheur de présider
la vie rurale une fontevraud
le patrimoine a une puissance de
suggestion et de création et les
résidences d'artistes
c'est très souvent dans ces lieux là
parce que ce sont des lieux inspirants
donc n'opposons pas le patrimoine qui
seraient fermés sur le passé et la
création qui serait ouverte sur le
présent et l'avenir les choses parce que
je me dis rapidement alors catherine
morin desailly monique de marco et
alexandra porsche au fond de teint et
six présidents salué la présence de ses
fans d'un c'est toujours un plaisir
de vous entendre un cher stéphane
pour rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
bruno retailleau beaucoup de
collectivités qui est alors maintenant
des politiques en faveur de la culture
en général du patrimoine et la création
particulier qui articule justement la
mise en valeur des lieux de patrimoine
est avec nous en résidence d'artiste
désir et d'expédition quand c'est ce qui
se fait dans pas mal de régions
maintenant je je note mais c'est ce qui
est bien sûr à à encourager pour
rebondir également sur ce qui a été
évoqué sur la répartition des
compétences je ne sais pas si
définitivement il faut attribuer les
compétences à tel ou tel niveau de
collectivités territoriales serait un
petit peu plus prudente comme l'a
rappelé bruno retailleau l'esprit de la
loi d'autres où les différents niveaux
de collectivités territoriales ont
réclamé à ce prix de conserver la
compétence sur la la culture maintenant
c'est vrai elle peut être
fléché ce qui se passe assez
naturellement j'observe que dans pas mal
de régions en réalité sont les communes
et les départements qui interviennent
sur les églises notamment de non
protégés et que les régions vont elles
aussi intervenir sur le patrimoine
religieux mais davantage sur les très
grands édifices qui nécessite la
mobilisation de fonds extrêmement
important les grandes abbayes cathédrale
les grandes églises qui sont pas
forcément d'ailleurs toujours propriété
de de l'état et que ça se fait un peu un
peu naturellement au gré des choses au
demeurant je pense que les communautés
de communes sont appelées davantage à
participer parce qu' une petite commune
très clairement elle ne peut pas trouver
les moyens d'aller restaurer son son
église et qu'à travers un projet à
l'échelle de la communauté de communes
qui donne aussi une affectation et un
usage partagé comme ça a été évoqué il
ya des tas d'exemples sur le modèle
québécois aussi qui est intéressante à
les regarder et ça permet de construire
un projet à l'échelle d'un bassin de vie
et ses projets ils peuvent aussi être
financés par les départements et les
régions manquent à des contrats de
territoire ou 4 et contrats de
développement culturel de territoire
dont je pense qu'il faut que chacun y
mette en réalité dans le cas de
peut-être de comités régionaux du
patrimoine aussi qui pourrait se créer
pour traiter cette question de l'urgence
du patrimoine religieux
ça me semble tout à fait utile de se
mobiliser aussi sur la question des
édifices en péril en absolu péril des
églises fermées je crois que
l'observatoire du patrimoine religieux
noter que 500 édifices étaient fermées
et d'autres sont très grand danger très
très grand danger donc comment d'abord
on accompagne les élus dans la
prévention de ces dangers mais la
situation sanitaire doit diviser et
surtout qu'est ce que l'on fait pour
créer peut-être un fonds d'urgence selon
lequel chacun participe mais ça c'est un
vrai sujet parce qu'on en a le cal
incendie de notre dame encore picot sont
pas encore complètement rétablie mais il
ya d'autres édifices religieux qui ont
brûlé et ce en passe de pouvoir brûler
un jour ou l'autre donc comment on
prévient ce père et moi c'est ma plus
grande préoccupation aujourd'hui est
l'usagé partagé doit être absolument
promu et on doit être inventif créatif
et je crois que ça redonne complètement
le sens qu en faire un lieu de
socialisation et à cet égard dernier
dernière remarque je pense qu'il
faudrait absolument que l'europe
participe à travers ses fonds de
cohésion les fonds de cohésion leader
fédère dans le mot cohésion on peut dire
que le patrimoine participe de la delà
de la cohésion et il faut une porte
d'entrée clairement établie désormais de
l'europe d'affirmation de ses
compétences rien n'empêche aujourd'hui
dans les traités européens et que l'on
puisse utiliser aussi ces fonds pour
pouvoir dans le cadre d'un projet de
territoire qui participe du
développement économique de la qualité
de vie de l'environnement agir monique
de marco je vous remercie
je suis donc sénatrice de la gironde un
très beau département aux riches en
patrimoine bien sûr je voulais rebondir
justement ce que vous nous dire aller
chercher des fonds et des fonds
européens se portent que c'est possible
on n'y pense pas suffisamment c'était
une de mes suggestions mais je reviens
sur une piste qui n'a pas été encore
abordé nous avons vu que suite à un
incendie notre dame
donc il ya eu une forte mobilisation de
mécènes milliardaire mais aussi donc de
simples citoyens qui ont contribué
financièrement à participer à la
rénovation
ne pensez-vous pas que qu'il faut lui
aussi motivés et intéressés ce petit
patrimoine local
donc un mécénat un mécénat peut-être
industriel particulier citoyens et
comment pourrait-on faire ceci à quelle
échelle
très synthétique
alexandra burke ce constat qui est
derrière son écran alexandra
il doit y avoir le micro alexandra
s'entend pas oui vous m'entendez bon
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je voudrais d'abord remercier
monsieur berne pour votre présence que
vos propos et explication et salue le
travail bien sûr de mes collègues alban
talons et pierre ouzoulias alors dans
une
tribune de juillet 2020 vous êtes revenu
sur l' incendie de la cathédrale notre
dame de paris vous avez souligné
d'ailleurs avec justesse que ce drame
avait tant marqué les esprits croyants
et non croyants du fait que chacun
pensait notre-dame éternel invulnérable
pourtant la réalité est tout autre et là
encore vous le constater en estimant à
5000 le nombre d'églises en souffrance à
travers la france alors bien que leur
entretien incombe et bien au maire tous
ne parviennent pas bien sûr à remplir
cette mission et se retrouve souvent
impuissant face au délabrement de la
patrimoine religieux on en a parlé tous
par ailleurs ne peuvent pas forcément
compter bien sûr sur le soutien de leur
conseil départemental comme c'est le cas
dans mon département des alpes-maritimes
où je siège et où nous avons pu soutenir
assez récemment deux chapelles notamment
à tivat ondes ou encore à nice alors
pour faire face à une partie notre
héritage qui part en poussière il est
impératif que nous réagissions et
d'oignons bien au maire qu'aux citoyens
des leviers d'action efficace le loto du
patrimoine bien sûr en étant en 2017 aux
alliés suggéré de rendre payantes
l'entrée des cathédrales pour les
touristes comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs
de nombreux édifices religieux dans le
monde donc ma question est la suivante
maintenez vous votre proposition et si
oui comment parvenir à distinguer donc à
faire payer le touriste du croyant qui
vient se recueillir
et enfin dernière intervention ces deux
saleen drexler qui est également
rapporteur des crédits budgétaires pour
notre émission sur le patrimoine oui
bonjour bonjour monsieur berne chers
collègues alors je suis en argentine a
remis son d'informations mais je tenais
vraiment être présente à cette audition
ce matin en qualité de rapporteur pour
le patrimoine mais surtout pour avoir
l'occasion de vous dire monsieur berne à
4h30 locale tout le respect et l estime
qu'il serait bien pour votre engagement
pour le patrimoine non protégé à la
collectivité européenne d'alsace où je
suis élue je suis déléguée au patrimoine
bâti et la mission qui est la mienne est
de tout faire pour sauver ce qui nous
reste de nos maisons en scène
alors sachez monsieur berne que vous
lire vous écouter vous regardez faire
aussi me donne eu le courage de porter
cette mission je sais que la sauvegarde
des maisons anciennes tient très à coeur
et que vous soutenez fortement
l'engagement associatif qui est très
fort dans ma région je voulais vous dire
que nous savoir à leurs côtés donne à
tous ceux qui se mobilisent qu'ils
donnent tout pour leur patrimoine les
meilleures raisons du monde les
meilleurs arguments et l'énergie ainsi
qu'il faut pour continuer leur combat
parce que c'est bien souvent de cela
qu'il s'agit
alors je suis élu d'une commune du 900
habitants qui on vient de présenter un
devis de 700000 euros pour rénover son
église sa pouvant pour effectuer les
travaux minimum qui permettrait d'éviter
qu'elle ne continue à se dégrader je
suis également présidente d'une société
d'histoire qui depuis 15 ans se
mobilisent pour préserver pour restaurer
pour valoriser et enfin pour transmettre
les traces de l'histoire juive qui a uni
en son temps les communautés juives et
chrétiennes du second et grâce à une
trentaine de bénévoles nous collectons
des fonds qui ont permis déjà de faire
ce travail de restaurer tout un quartier
d'ailleurs je vous invite à venir nous
voir un psy mouvement aussi et ensuite
nous ferons la même chose pour notre
église à dix minutes de chez moi la
commune grisonne 1500 habitants elle a
acheté il ya une quinzaine d'années la
belle synagogue du village qui était
devenu un squat pour tenter protéger ce
lieu qui racontent qu'ils témoignent
aussi l histoire de nos petites
communautés juives malheureusement aucun
projet donc aucun financement du permet
d'envisager sa restauration et comme
notre église à durmenach dans mon
village est se dégradent chaque année
davantage et un jour il faudra la
détruire pour des raisons de sécurité
alors les finances des communes sont
aujourd'hui ce qu'elles sont là dit tout
à l'heure on le sait tous pour garder
pour faire venir des femmes il faut
construire de nouvelles écoles des
équipements culturels et sportifs c'est
très bien on est tous d'accord là dessus
mais comment dans ce contexte nous
parlementaires pourrions-nous à soutenir
les élus qui font le choix courageux de
prioriser de reconvertir d'intégrer leur
patrimoine culte dans les projets de la
mandature tout en s'assurant de
l'adhésion des habitants de leur
territoire et ses missionnaires
merci sabine fait partie des rares
personnes qui font lever les sénateurs à
4 heures du matin hier j'ai très touchés
mais il avait correspondu avec avec
madame est exclu je vais essayer de
répondre si vous me l'autorisé à tous
ces points je pensais j'ai écouté toutes
vos interventions et ça m'a beaucoup
touché et je pense à un point majeur
qu'il faut absolument qu'on martèle
auprès de l'opinion publique et des et
des élus dans notre pays il ne faut
surtout pas opposer les pierres aux
hommes parce que et
il est trop facile de dire avez vous
défendez les vieilles pierres mais vous
défendez pas il y avait tellement de
drames en ce moment la pauvreté le lait
etc non les les les les pierres
révèle les hommes et les hommes réveille
les pierres ça c'est la devise d'actavis
talent que je reprends mon compte mais
pour paraphraser lamartine on n'a pas un
coeur pour les hommes un coeur pour les
pierres on a du coeur où on en a pas et
je crois que quand on a envie de sauver
derrière les pierres il y a des
aventures humaines chaque pierre de
notre pays est bien raconte une histoire
quand les langues se taisent parce qu'on
apprend plus les pierres parlent encore
et donc c'est ça que je veux sauver
c'est à dire que c'est il faut que l'on
comprenne que ce patrimoine religieux
c'est notre histoire qu'on soit croyant
ou qu'on ne le soit pas c'est notre
histoire et on n'a pas le droit de
l'abandonner parce que derrière il ya
des hommes et des femmes qui les ont
bâties et qu'aujourd'hui encore il y a
quarante cinq mille emplois qui sont
directement liés à ces métiers d'art qui
sont des savoir faire d'excellence à la
française qu'on est en train de perdre
pour certains alors évidemment il ya le
chantier de notre dame et notre dame
c'est un peu la fpt l'arbre qui cache la
forêt c'est à dire je ne fais pas de jeu
de mots avec la forêt de notre dame qui
est malheureusement un influent bbc on
devrait saisir et on n'a pas encore fait
saisir la chance ce chantier de notre
dame pour valoriser les métiers d'art
pour faire en sorte
et bien partout il y aider des jeunes
qui ont envie d'apprendre c'est métier
de couvreur de tailleur de pierre de
charpentier de vitrailliste même s'il
faut se battre à l'europe pour
évidemment qu'on nous maintiennent le
plomb pour les pour les pour les vitraux
bon ça c'est un autre combat qu'il
faudra mener dans les semaines qui
viennent mais voyez c'est ce sont des
chantiers du patrimoine qui donne de la
colonne vertébrale je prends toujours là
ggg aider une association qui s'appelle
acta vista ce sont des jeunes qui sont
en dessous des moins jeunes d'ailleurs
qu'ils sont en en déconnexion de la vie
qui sont en grand danger de basculer
dans
parfois dans un mauvais côté eh bien on
leur redonne une colonne vertébrale
grâce au patrimoine il se réveille le
matin et ils vont travailler sur les
chantiers du patrimoine et ils partent
avec un diplôme un métier et on les a
sauvés donc ça c'est le premier point ne
poseront pas les pierres et les êtres
humains maintenant je vais répondre à
toutes vos questions
je réponds peut-être même d'ex clair
parce que parce qu'elle est loin et
qu'elle est et quel est il est tôt je
pense que là où il ya un moyen des décès
coeur de bourg on a fait coeur de ville
mais l'action coeur de bourg devrait
permettre de recréer du lien social dans
les bourgs de nos de nos villages et
c'est vrai que remettons l'église au
coeur du village elle est là elle est
comme monsieur retailleau le disait très
justement c'est pas seulement un lieu de
culte c'est un lieu de culture et même
la prévôté le disait aussi vous avez
raison de le lire c'est de l'art c'est
de l'histoire c'est de la culture c'est
du mobilier cdd statut cdd tableau c'est
aussi des des registres c'est tout cela
qu'il faut préserver parce que c'est
notre histoire il n'y a pas de raison de
sauver uniquement les grands monuments
ccc c'est ça qui est injuste que j'ai
trouvé injuste dans notre dame de paris
si vous voulez c'est qu'on trouve 900
millions pour sauver notre dame parce
qu'on est tous bouleversés mais qu'à
aucun moment on dise ok si un peu s'il
ya trop d'argent eh bien on va le
saupoudrer pour sauver les petites
églises de nos campagnes moi ce qui me
touche le plus c'est la ruralité c'est
que ce et cm r dans ces communes qui se
démène pour sauver leur église ils n'ont
aucune prise directe sur la
médiatisation
personne ne s'est publiquement déjà
comme je l'aï dit un ministre j'ai perdu
qu'on m'explique pourquoi je vaux -
quand je vis à la campagne dans mon
village je sais c'était une forme
d'injustice
de ne pas être illégal déjà on n'a pas
de 3g on a même on et edge 1 on a même
pas de téléphone pour qu'on n'a rien on
n'a pas de service public on n'a pas de
médecin et en plus on nous détruit notre
église on la laisse tomber en ruine gypa
l'église au sens religieux du terme mais
au sens culturel
ça c'est quelque chose au-delà alors il
y eut cette polémique quand j'avais
parlé je réponds en même temps la
question de l'entrée des cathédrales
j'avais juste émis cette idée que
regarder quand vous allez place saint
marc à milan à pardon à à venise mais à
milan à la cathédrale au duomo à firenze
ou milano vous avez vous avez une file
pour eux pour aller prier et puis vous
avez une file pour visiter et vous ne
dérangeait personne et vous payer un
droit d'entrée pour visiter mais
évidemment j'ai eu des discussions avec
tous les heureux avec monseigneur
vingt-trois c'était un peu compliqué
avec monseigneur ravel c'était plus
simple avec avec d'autres c'était ça
s'est révélé plus simple aussi c'est que
healy a depuis
1905 il y à une rancune tenace du clergé
affectataire contre l'état vous nous
avez pris nos édifices religieux eh bien
vous payez alors moi j'ai juste mis à
plat cette chose dans très bien voulait
pas qu'on paye pour rentrer dans les
églises mais dans ce cas là pourquoi
vous faites payer pour l'entrée du
trésor pourquoi vous faites payer pour
l'entrée de la crypte pourquoi vous
faites payer pour les boutiques pourquoi
vous faites payer pour aller visiter les
tours de notre-dame c'était une vraie
question aussi puisque ça appartient à
l'état vous n'avez pas fait de l'argent
sur le dos de l'état quand même ou alors
vous donner une il ya une licence il ya
une une convention qui signait alors là
il était gêné j'ai j'ai senti j'ai
demandé à l'état au cabinet du président
la république qu'on fasse qu'on fasse
une étude sur justement toutes les
dérogations et à l'érable de strasbourg
vous le savez très bien on ferme à 11h45
on fait payer le ticket d'entrée pour
aller voir l'horloge astronomique et
puis de bombay puis hop on trouve
gratuit à 12h15
ccc des facilités qui sont donnés mais
dans ce cas-là ouvrons la discussion
alors tout cela vient du fait que l'état
doit garantir le culte gratuit donc j'ai
plus toucher à cette question de faire
payer les l'entrée des cathédrales parce
que j'ai vu que c'était un sujet épineux
et que ça dit c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre un pays laïque où on a
on a on april et les biens du clergé
avec d'autres pays par exemple
l'allemagne ou l'autriche l'allemagne et
un est un exemple toutes les églises
toutes les tous les édifices religieux
sont superbement bien entretenues tous
pourquoi pas ce que vous payez l'impôt
sur le culte est un impôt du culte et
donc si vous voulez vous faire enterrer
selon les rites catholique juif
protestant et bien il faut payer toute
votre vie et donc avec 7,1 c'est un pot
comprenez nous on veut pas payer et puis
après on verra mais bon ça c'est une
autre question ça ces genres de voiliers
en allemagne ots - le patrimoine
religieux est très bien entretenu alors
maintenant la conversion monsieur paco
vous répondre à votre vision la
convention église concert ya est
évidemment le clergé affectataire la
plume voilà on lui tend le bras en
permanence quand on veut organiser des
concerts dans les églises et donc ils
demandent évidemment à ce que ça soit
plutôt plutôt spirituel plutôt religieux
ce que je peux entendre aussi pour faire
un concert rock dans une église 20 ans
évidemment il ya 2 200 je crois qu'il ya
200 que j'avais noté le chiffre il ya
plus de 250 églises qui depuis 1950 ont
été désaffectés et qui sont qui sont
désacralisés et qu'on peut utiliser
pourquoi pas les convertir effectivement
mais avec l'accord du public avec
l'accord de nos concitoyens parce que
n'oubliez pas qu'autour des églises de
campagne mondiale cimetière la plupart
du temps donc quel respect qui est dû
aux morts est elle respectée dû à
l'histoire donc encore une fois ça ne
peut pas se faire sans concertation de
mon point de vue mais pourquoi pas c'est
aussi une possibilité
madame longpré voter vous avez évoqué le
problème l'assistance à la maîtrise
d'ouvragé
le montage financier notamment pour trim
onekey et non protégées évidemment
l'état qui n'a pas les moyens de vous
aider en revanche à des fonctionnaires
qui ont les moyens de vous demander des
comptes en permanence et je l' ai vécu
pour protéger pour sauver mon monument
sans demander jamais un euro de
subvention publique et donc la seule
chose qui me faisait c'est des
ordonnancements ça vous avez le droit ça
venait pas le droit la couleur comme ci
comme ça très bien vous êtes chez vous
allez faites comme vous voulez leur
ai-je dit à la femme du nord vous êtes
quand même chez vous à bon je peux
choisir ma couleur c'est les factures
augmentent fatalement mais je pense que
là il ya peut-être une jeep à une
déréglementation mais peut-être qu'à une
il ya une sensibilité de l'état par
rapport aux métiers d'art je pense qu'on
pourrait donner la possibilité à tous
ces jeunes dans les chantiers est bien
de faire de participer sans que
forcément gay alors qu' un architecte du
patrimoine je trouve ça utile vous avez
en a j'étais pas très pour convenu les
les ldd des architectes et d'aider des
bâtiments de france
ce n'était pas pour non plus parce que
voyez-vous autrefois ça protège lé maire
beaucoup plus que cela ne les empêchait
de de tourner en rond ça les protégés is
défaut c'est vous comprenez les abf il
faut leur redonner leur leur puissance
en tout cas une certaine un avis plus
que consultatif parce que la bêtise ça a
été de faire quand vous vouliez
construire une une chose horrible chez
vous et bien la bf 10e bernand ça vous
pouvez pas autorisés donc le maire
disait as soon as sont administrés moi
je suis pour mais mon abf ne veux pas ça
le protéger il garder sa voix maintenant
il dit s'il dit non il perd la voix de
son électeur s'il dit oui il à moosch
son village voilà donc le choix et effet
c'est pour ça que je rencontre de
village de plus en plus amoché et c'est
un vrai problème plus généralement du
patrimoine donc je pense que pour tout
je vois tous les dossiers qu'on reçoit
avec la fondation du patrimoine qui nous
remontent et qui ne dépendent pas de la
drac puisqu'ils ne sont pas protégés
jusqu'à présent il ya que la générosité
publique il n'y a que la fondation du
patrimoine puisque on lance pour vous
savez que la faune du patrimoine on
lance des quêtes un deck et en ligne
d'aidé des cagnottes enfants et avec la
mission berne c'est la seule chose qu'on
fait pour le patrimoine non protégé
d'ailleurs dans le choix qui est fait
aujourd'hui on insiste davantage sur les
monuments qui ne sont pas protégés
puisqu'on sait que j'ai obtenus et grâce
aux sénateurs d'ailleurs à ce que à
l'euro près soit compensé les les taxes
sur le loto du patrimoine mais ça ne
peut revenir que pour des bâtiments
protégés vous l'avez bien compris parce
qu'on ne peut pas remettre de l'argent
de l'état à des à des bâtiments qui ne
sont pas protégés donc je suis obligé de
faire une péréquation pour faire en
sorte qu' on est davantage des monuments
non protégés pour pour pour que
puisqu'on sait que les protégés
recevront en plus la manne financière du
des crédits qui sont qui sont recrédités
pour pour pour le
loto du patrimoine dont j'espère que la
pérennité est assurée j'ai tout à
l'heure une rendez-vous jeu je sais que
c'est enregistré ces publics je la haute
autorité de régulation des jeux veut
renier les griffes du loto du patrimoine
trouve que c'est scandaleux qu'on réunit
les gens avec 15 euros de tickets alors
ça les choque pas qu'on bingo etc mais
ça ça sans doute la présidente ne va pas
souvent dans les pmu dans les petits
villages mais je vais aller défendre mon
bout de gras et je me bats avec la fonde
avec la fondation du patrimoine et la
française des jeux pour qu'on maintienne
le loto du patrimoine ça a été voté
choix décidés par le président public
votée par les députés les sénateurs mais
je suis encore obligé alors qu'on a on a
récolté en cinq ans près de 200 millions
d'euros pour le patrimoine c'est quand
même une contribution importante et ce
qui les gêne c'est que c'est si vous
voulez c'est fléché voilà il faudrait
dire que c'est pour toutes les bonnes
causes mais est fléché sauf que cette
dame qui visiblement n'a pas
connaissance des dd de l'histoire de
france a oublié de banc de souvenirs que
la loterie le loto a été créée pour
sauver le patrimoine pour le construire
pardon le loto a été créé en italie pour
le patrimoine importés par françois 1er
à la halle à la renaissance pour
construire du patrimoine l'église s'y
est opposé mais l'huile 15 a repris
l'idée a construit l'église sainte
geneviève qui deviendra le panthéon puis
ensuite l'école militaire a été
construite avec l'argent des du loto de
la lotto la loterie et donc j'ai
argumenté de cela j'ai relu et de cela
pour que ce que le loto avait permis de
faire au xviiie siècle l'auto puisse
permettre de protéger le patrimoine mais
bon il va falloir se battre oui rien
n'est jamais acquis dans ce pays on ne
peut jamais dormir tranquille ensuite
l'entretien du patrimoine je pense que
j'irais même plus loin vous avez vous
voyez donné une très bonne idée je pense
d'abord qu'il faut faire un inventaire
complet du patrimoine
je pense que c'est une chose urgente un
inventaire complet du patrimoine
paysager une des zones qu'on ne peut pas
toucher on ne mettra pas d'éoliennes on
ne mettra pas de choses immondes qui
vont dénaturer nos paysages de carte
postale
ça c'est une première chose le
patrimoine bâti ensuite le patrimoine
religieux le patrimoine castrats le
patrimoine industriel et ouvrier je
revendique le fait de défendre la
mémoire ouvrière de notre pays je suis
contre le fait qu'on détruise du
patrimoine industriel où nous arrière
grands parents travaillent et ont trimé
je pense que c'est bien de les ré valeur
revalorisé de faire des espaces de
coworking d'en faire des quand je vois
des manufactures qui ferment je vois par
exemple alors à sarreguemines j'ai vu
que l'ancien ils ont fermé mais on a
fait un écomusée les écomusées c'est
intéressant ça permet justement de
redonner une nouvelle valorisation d'eau
que je crois qu'il faut faire un
inventaire du patrimoine immobilier des
statuts du patrimoine vous avez raison
madame la sénatrice vous avez raison il
faut défendre tous ses livres tous ces
registres tous eu toutes ses aises
bibliothèque que je vois dispersé
j'achète moi-même dès que je vois d'aidé
qui concerne mon église abbatiale
j'essaye de récupérer mais ça me fend le
coeur de voir que on des fonds entier de
ce patrimoine écrit de notre mémoire
collective est en train de partir à
l'encan et brûlé sous le feu des
enchères
c'est un drame absolu ce feu-là
personnes non non non non on parle
jamais donc est d'abord un pat un
inventaire total puis ensuite je moi je
ferai alors le mot peut-être va choquer
une police du patrimoine on ne compare
est de faire n'importe quoi vous savez
en 1825 puis en 1830 de victor hugo a
écrit son livre sur stop aux
démolisseurs parce qu'on a voulu
détruire une chapelle de l'an et ses
talents qu'est né tout cet élan
justement de victor hugo pour pour
écrire ce pamphlet stop aux démolisseurs
il a été choqué c'est qu'au 19e siècle
on continue sur les méthodes d'avant on
fait du passé table rase et ont bâti par
dessus sans se préoccuper de l'histoire
ddd j'allais dire de la sédimentation
des siècles de ce qui s'était passé
avant c'est plus possible aujourd'hui
d'abord parce que il ya une conscience
collective de la prise de conscience de
l'importance du patrimoine d'abord pour
nos racines pour notre histoire pour
notre identité mais aussi simplement
pour notre portefeuille parce que c'est
ce qui permet de faire vivre des
villages dont le seul trésor je le
rappelle c'est le patrimoine religieux
souvent ou le château qui est pas très
loin c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya encore
un commerce est ce qui fait qu on achète
des cartes postales c'est ce qui fait
qu'il ya parfois une auberge où on peut
dormir et on peut se restaurer daube c
c'est un non sens de laisser détruire ce
patrimoine donc je pense qu'il faut que
cette police du patrimoine puisse aussi
édicter des règles on ne peut pas
démolir ce patrimoine on doit au
contraire le protéger et garantir vous
avez raison cette ligne cette fameuse
ligne d'entretien du patrimoine c'est si
vous n'entretenait pas le patrimoine la
facture est exponentielle et à la fin du
compte est bien avec la loi élan vous
pouvez et les lois toutes les lois qui
ont été votées depuis pas touche sait
plus comment vous appelez ça ça c'est de
nous autres et bien on juge que c'est
vétustes et que c'était donc très
dangereux pour pour les gens donc il
faut il faut détruire et donc voilà
comment on aboutit à la destruction d'un
patrimoine inestimable
donc pardon de m'enflammer mai mais je
le dis parce que j'ai participé au jury
d'un magazine qui s'appelle pèlerins
pèlerin magazine donne des prix chaque
année je suis membre de leur jeu oui eh
ben voilà il me j'ai eu comme ça j'avais
pris plein la figure d'une cinquantaine
d'églises qui sont toutes en déréliction
qui sont toutes en train de tomber en
ruine mais on doit donner un prix 20
mille euros ici 50000 là mais c'est
c'est pas rien c'est pas rien ça va
aider donc je pense qu'il faut mettre
tous tous se font en commun pour essayer
de sauver six églises mais d'abord faut
les inventorier faut les répertorier
tout ce patrimoine religieux non
protégés et il ya la sauvegarde de l'art
français qui vient aussi au secours à la
fois des retables du patrimoine
religieux mobilier mais vous savez on a
eu un gros problème avec le mobilier
c'est que la ministre de la culture les
ministres de la culture successivement
des vous toucher à tout pouvait sauver
le patrimoine bâti mais vous ne touchez
pas au patrimoine mobilier c'est pas
votre affaire donc j'ai pas pu m'en
occuper j'ai par exemple insisté pour
que la bibliothèque fesch d'ajaccio
puisse être un site emblématique de la
mission bien nommé je n'avais pas le
droit de me couper des livres donc on a
sauvé la halle enveloppe mais à
l'intérieur tout pourri et là je peux
rien faire donc de vous voyez on est on
est dans cette contradiction est là où
donc je crois que vous avez raison il
faut que vraiment se mobilisent pour les
archives pour les livres que peut être
l'idée de bruno retailleau et très
intéressante les archives
départementales
je vais manger trouve énormément de
choses dans les archives départementales
qui ont vocation à protéger ses archives
qui sont la mémoire la même vous savez
si les livres disparaît si les noms des
gens disparaissent pas c'est la mort
assurée donc c'est ça qu'il faut
protéger parce que on est là pour faire
oeuvre de vie encore une fois c'est pas
des pierres conso c'est des âmes des
gens des gens qui ont vécu qui ont aimé
qu'ils ont souffert ensuite les églises
du 19e oui souvent ce sont les églises
du 19e siècle qui sont dans en danger
pourquoi parce que on ne connaissait pas
les méthodes on a on a mélangé des
matériaux vous avez très bien dit
monsieur retailleau vous avez je suis
membre de la fondation saint-louis on
essaie de sauver la lâche des travaux
sur la chapelle royale saint louis de
dreux et on a ce problème entre la
maçonnerie il est la pierre le le mieux
on a commencé à mettre de l'acier qui
s'érode évidemment avec les
ruissellements tout ça fait exploser les
pierres c'est beaucoup plus cher
beaucoup plus compliqué de restaurer une
église du 19e siècle là il faut faire
aussi une expertise essayer de les de
les recenser de voir ce qu'on peut faire
et ne pas oublier le patrimoine du xxème
siècle sachant que à partir de 1905 ça
appartient au diocèse et peut être
restaurée aussi alors leur vient l'idée
de fonds européens
j'en ai parlé beaucoup avec marie à
gabriel qui est la commissaire européen
elle a tout à fait conscience europa
nostra essaie de faire ce qu'ils peuvent
mais ils n'ont pas de moyens et donc ils
n'ont aucun moyen ils ont juste la
communication alors on vous remet une
jolie un joli prix en récompense mais il
n'y a pas d'argent pour aider des
églises ou le patrimoine religieux je
pense qu'il ya énormément de bonne
volonté il a énormément de gens qui
veulent aider je crois qu'il faut les
mettre ensemble il faut créer vraiment
un fond vous avez raison un fonds commun
enfants citoyens font alors peut-être on
peut assigner cette mission à la
fondation du patrimoine qui fait ça très
bien où l observatoire l'observatoire du
patrimoine religieux il faut peut-être
essayer de travailler ensemble pour
trouver des solutions pour que toutes
ces petites rivières et bien
confluer et aller ensemble vers aider le
patrimoine religieux mais encore une
fois il ya aussi des centres bourgs faux
pas dans l'action que l'état mène dans
l'est dans les bourgs faut jamais
oublier les églises parce que les
églises ou les synagogues
j'étais très touché de ce que racontait
madame d'ex clair à la fois son église
qui a lui demande 900000 euros la petite
synagogue
alsacienne qu'elle rachète mais ils ont
pas les moyens
vous savez on est j'ai l'impression
d'être dans un bateau qui prend l'eau et
d'écoper avec une cuillère à soupe et et
c'est terrible parce que d'un côté j'ai
l'église affectataire qui m'appelle
venez nous aider un père une
soeur une mère eux supérieurs qui
m'appellent pour son couvent ensuite
j'ai le grand rabbin haïm korsia qui
m'appelle ma synagogue de bayonne quand
est-ce que tu t'en occupes enfin vous
voyez j'ai l'impression d'être
d'être d'être devenu l'interlocuteur
pardon de le dire mais vous savez quand
j'ai commencé ma mission il ya eu un
article très méchant de monsieur jeu
j'oublie son nom dans le monde qui
disait il se substitue à la force
publique c'est pas ma vocation je viens
là bénévolement parce que contrairement
à eux tous je ne suis pas payé je fais
ça avec mon argent et mes moyens et mon
temps et c'est une mission bénévole que
président de la république m'a confiées
et on vient me dire vous substituer la
force publique ne vient en soutien mais
mais pensant pour comment vous expliquez
que toutes les demandes viennent vers
moi ouvert la fondation du patrimoine
maintenant qui la cheville ouvrière de
ma mission ce n'est pas normal c'est
qu'il ya une déficience de l'état est
d'ailleurs le rapport delà de la cour
des comptes le montre bien il ya un
problème justement voulait peut-être
luge je viens d'en lire les grandes
lignes c'est quand même c'est comme un
problème la politique de l'état en
soussou sur le patrimoine pose quand
même un certain nombre de questions donc
le patrimoine religieux ou à la poule
j'espère avoir répondu en partie à vos
questions j'y suis pas content quand
l'église est d'accord pour désacraliser
par contre je une petite pique et je le
dis parce que je le vois dans certaines
églises le clergé n'est pas toujours
notre notre notre allié
le il ya beaucoup d'églises ou parfois
des install des filons mais des
projecteurs on met des
les l'église est affectataire mais elle
doit respecter les règles du patrimoine
et je pense que c'est bien de temps en
temps de le rappeler aussi donc moi je
veux bien les secourir le
secourir le patrimoine religieux mais il
faut aussi que ceux qui en ont la la
gestion au quotidien qui sont
affectataire de ce patrimoine le
défendent aussi
merci pour votre enthousiasme une fille
pour la passion que vous avez communiqué
vous avez vu que c'est pas sûr et
entièrement partagée par l'ensemble des
des membres de notre commission à
travers les interventions des uns et des
autres la préoccupation qui est la bonne
partageons complètement c'est une
préoccupation dont on doit
collectivement
faire se faire l'écho et le porte parole
parce qu'on voit l'immensité votre image
à la fin de votre propos sur
l'impression que vous avez d'écoper avec
une cuillère c'est un peu le sentiment
que nous que nous avons tous et qui
justifie pleinement la mobilisation de
chacun sur ce sujet central de la
protection du patrimoine en tout cas
nous avons toujours plaisir à vous
entendre et surtout à travailler avec
vous et nous continuerons de faire bien
introduit on a noté votre rendez-vous
cet après-midi j'espère qu'ils se savent
qu'il y aura bien
un moment où l'autre
parent dans les départements les régions
les fonds européens la terre et ses îles
mèdes elle et les p ô terre aussi les
parcs les pays nous aide parce que c'est
un gage voit qu'on a comme
les seuls fierté que je peux avoir vous
savez c'est la grâce et ses cénac parce
que c'est donc on n'était pas nombreux 1
au début et donc franchement d'avoir
réussi il ya souillac maintenant on va
ça c'est des grands monuments mais et là
où je rebondis aussi pardon j'ai
toujours j'ai l'esprit d'escalier mais
catherine morin desailly par led et en
europe peut-être on devrait travailler
sur les chemins les chemins de
compostelle les chemins les les chemins
clunisiens aussi il y à là qu'ils
quittent j'allais dire qu'ils
commandaient heureux sont européens sont
des chemins européens essaient de l'aide
européenne qui peut apporter abondé pour
nos églises voilà merci en tout cas de
m'avoir écouté je sais que j'ai toujours
une écoute attentive au sénat c'est pour
ça que j'ai toujours plaisir à revenir
vous voir et en tout cas pardon d'être
d'être un passionné engagé mais je fais
ça tout mon coeur et je vais continuer
jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive
merci à vous mais bien sûr on aura
plaisir à renouveler ses échanges avec
vous et et rester vigilants et nous ne
manquerons pas certainement cet
après-midi d'interroger le ministre la
question du patrimoine même si nous
avons beaucoup d'autres sujets abordés
avec elle mais c'est évidemment le
ministère de la culture est au centre
de ce travail cette conférence n'est
plus en cours d'enregistrement